>>> HELLO, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
THIS SUNDAY.
I'M FREDRICKA WHITFIELD.
WE BEGIN THIS HOUR WITH
CELEBRATION TURNING INTO TRAGEDY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF GEORGIA.
JUST HOURS AFTER THE FOOTBALL
TEAM WAS HONORED FOR WINNING A
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP ONE OF
THEIR KEY PLAYERS, 20-YEAR-OLD,
WAS KILLED IN A CAR CRASH ALONG
WITH A MEMBER OF THE FOOTBALL
STAFF, 24-YEAR-OLD CHANDLER
LaCROIX.
CNN IS LIVE IN ATHENS, GEORGIA.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> Reporter: WE JUST GOT A
STATEMENT INDICATING THIS
HAPPENED AT 2:45 EARLY THIS
MORNING.
THAT CAR WAS TRAVELING
SOUTHBOUND ON THIS ROAD BEHIND
ME JUST PAST THIS CURVE RIGHT
HERE AND THEN, FRED, FOR SOME
REASON THAT CAR LEFT THE
ROADWAY, STRUCK THIS POWER POLE
RIGHT HERE.
WE SAW UTILITY CREWS IN THE LAST
HOUR OR SO REPLACING AND FIXING
THIS POWER POLE, AND THEN THE
CAR CONTINUED, FRED.
YOU CAN SEE THE DEBRIS, THE
FALLEN TREE LIMBS WHERE IT
STRUCK A TREE.
AS WE MAKE OUR WAY OVER HERE I
WILL SHOW YOU THE EXACT SPOT
WHERE THIS CAR CAME TO REST
CONTINUING PAST THIS SLOPE RIGHT
HERE AND ENDING AT THIS LOCATION
RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF THIS
APARTMENT COMPLEX.
GEORGIA BULLDOGS FOOTBALL PLAYER
DEVIN WILLOCK, 20 YEARS OLD, A
RECRUITING STAFF MEMBER, AND TWO
OTHER STAFF MEMBERS WERE ALL
INSIDE THE CAR AT THE TIME OF
THE CRASH.
WILLOCK DIED HERE AT THE SCENE.
THE RECRUITING STAFF MEMBER,
CHANDLER LECROY WAS TAKEN TO THE
HOSPITAL BUT LATER DIED.
WILLOCK WAS AN OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN, A REDSHIRT SOPHOMORE.
HE PLAYED EVERY SINGLE GAME THIS
YEAR.
WE HAVE A STATEMENT FROM THE
HEAD FOOTBALL COACH.
HE SAYS, QUOTE, WE ARE ALL
HEARTBROKEN AND DEVASTATED.
DEVIN WAS AN OUTSTANDING YOUNG
MAN IN EVERY WAY AND WAS ALWAYS
SMILING.
HE WAS A GREAT TEAMMATE AND A
JOY TO COACH.
CHANDLER WAS A VALUABLE MEMBER
TO OUR FOOTBALL STAFF AND
BROUGHT AN INCREDIBLE ATTITUDE
AND ENERGY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE ALSO HAVE A PIECE OF SOUND
HERE WE WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU
FROM SENATOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK
ADDRESSING THE DEATHS DURING
CHURCH SERVICE WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN MARKING MARTIN LUTHER KING
JR. DAY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> SAD NEWS THIS MORNING.
AFTER WINNING A NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP AGAIN, WE'RE
SADDENED TO HEAR THAT DEATH AND
GRIEF HAS VISITED THE UNIVERSITY
OF GEORGIA FOOTBALL TEAM,
GEORGIA FOOTBALL PLAYER AND A
STAFF MEMBER WERE KILLED THIS
MORNING IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
WE LIFT THESE FAMILIES IN
PRAYER.
>> Reporter: AND, FRED, AS YOU
MENTIONED, JUST ADDING TO THE
SADNESS OF THIS TRAGIC EVENT IS
THE FACT JUST HOURS PRIOR TO THE
CRASH THE TEAM HAD JUST
CELEBRATED THEIR NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP VICTORY DOING A
VICTORY PARADE RIGHT HERE IN
ATHENS, GEORGIA, A CELEBRATION.
IN FACT, WE HAVE VIDEO FROM OUR
CNN AFFILIATE WXIA SHOWING THE
TEAM JUST SO HAPPY ON TOP OF
THAT FIRE TRUCK TO CHEERING
CROWDS, JUST SO HAPPY, AND NOW
TO HAVE THIS DEVASTATING AND
TRAGIC TURN OF EVENTS HERE
ENDING IN THE DEATHS OF TWO
MEMBERS OF THIS FOOTBALL PROGRAM
IS HORRIBLE.
AND, FRED, AS FAR AS THE TWO
OTHER MEMBERS WHO WERE IN THAT
CAR, PART OF THE FOOTBALL
PROGRAM, THEY WERE HURT IN THE
CRASH, ARE IN STABLE CONDITION.
ONE HAD MINOR INJURIES AND WE'RE
LEARNING THE OTHER HAD SERIOUS
INJURIES.
AS FAR AS THE UNIVERSITY, THEY
ARE OFFERING MEDICAL A